i guess this this film if nothing else
also
gives this idea of bullies are bad
bullies are bad
except for when you become the bully to
beat up on the bully
like it's it's again there's so many
contradictions within this story
that i don't even understand what it's
trying to
say and if it even came in on
the subway train where arthur is is
riding home
and he has this laugh like jacqueline
said
in her synopsis up top and he and it's
just this this thing that he can't
really control
it's not laughing because something's
funny he has a laugh but then
he also has this laugh where if he's
panicking or if he's actually struggling
with something that's his response
which is obviously throwing people off
left and right including these
wall street bro [ __ ] on the subway
that decide to
for no other reason than just to get
some kicks on friday night
beat him up and and mock him and bully
him and so watching that
we've seen so many coming-of-age films
we've seen so many action movies we've
seen so many dramas where
we're we're not sure who we're rooting
for then all of a sudden you see someone
get bullied and you just want to be
there in the room and say it's okay
and put your arms around them and lift
them back up
and we're naturally inclined to do that
even when it's arthur fleck and we know
what he could become
watching this movie but in that moment
you just
you feel for him so much and that
feeling gets weaponized later in the
movie i think in a very artistic way
that it can be taken the wrong way for
sure but it also
is back to jaclyn's point robert of
when do you stop rooting for someone if
they were bullied and that made them the
bully
when do we stop pulling for them and
when do we say okay well
no now we need to intervene with
a batman like superhero that's in the
sequel but one thing about the bullies
one thing about the bullies before
robert answers who are these
wall street bros who are also well
versed with stephen sondheim
i would like to know who are these
people singing stephen sondheim
on new york subways i can see that dude
talking about sports scores i can see
that dude
even rapping inappropriately to kendrick
lamar lyrics
but sondheim that was the choice hey
cocaine is a hell of a drug and it was
everywhere on wall street and whatever
gotham's wall street is back in the 70s
and 80s
yeah no no i mean i i think that
for one that's hysterical but yeah i
mean i think that just goes to show you
like that you know the kind of
metaphor that they're trying to go for
with the whole new york thing to begin
with
uh you know to begin with right like how
um
how this gotham city is kind of you know
they filmed a lot of it in new york it's
supposed to be like a 1970s 1980s
new york vibe where the streets are full
of trash like the social services are
starved out
you know for like metal from mental
health clinics and
to just literal everything in the
society just looking bad
and entire communities just being
displaced this is like post
capitalism post-stage capitalism like at
its finest
meanwhile you know which is in real life
you know
in real life over 40 of wealth in this
country is inherited from like
generation to generation um and we see a
thomas wayne in here
who is you know i don't know if
necessarily self-made
or you know necessarily inherited the
same wealth but we know bruce wayne
inherits the health
that wealth eventually but when
uh but but you know seeing like these
wall street guys who actually work for
the wayne corporation
somebody who in this film we see him
multiple times go on the news and say
you know people who aren't rich people
who you know do these kind of things are
clowns to begin with so he's already
kind of
uh he already kind of has like a down
looking
opinion on people at the bottom anyway
and then joker's kind of just looking up
like i don't know i like you know like
y'all
already cut my medication you already
cut my therapy like what am i supposed
to do
[Music]
you